después de más de un año de protestas
por un bosque antiguo en faire y tres
docenas de manifestantes siguen
manteniéndose firmes en este campamento
improvisado
las reciclar y como sabes comer menos
carnes son todas cosas buenas pero no es
suficiente no va a cambiar las prácticas
destructivas que tenemos en marcha a un
ritmo suficientemente rápido
nada que no sea presionar a nuestros
gobiernos de esta manera y a diferentes
empresas para que cambien sus prácticas
va a mejorar las cosas contame qué te
parece
el mes pasado el máximo tribunal de la
columbia británica dictaminó que la
tabla puede continuar y prohibió a los
manifestantes bloquear las carreteras de
acceso a la explotación forestal la
policía ha desmantelado los principales
campamentos de protesta en la ladera
pero estos activistas no ceden su
objetivo es frenar las máquinas
escondiéndose en las zonas de tala a
pesar del riesgo que supone la caída de
árboles the work
funcionó no cortaron más árboles en ese
lugar
aterrador
estas son las cosas que tenemos que
hacer tenemos que exponerlas
como ya saben no hay victoria sin
sacrificio
desde la sentencia del tribunal los
manifestantes sólo pueden acceder al
lugar a pie monsoon y mongoose son
antiguos plantadores de árboles tienen
que recorrer un camino de cuatro horas
para reunirse con los pocos activistas
que siguen en el campamento a la espera
de suministros
el queso es muy importante eso en el
camino nos detenemos frente a un cedro
rojo apodado árbol del gran padre se ha
convertido en un símbolo de su lucha
para impedir la tala de estos árboles
milenarios
y ese hermoso me siento bastante
bastante privilegiada también de alguna
manera protegida en medio de este
enfrentamiento el gobierno de la
columbia británica anunció que
suspenderá la tala en 2,6 millones de
hectáreas de bosques antiguos durante
dos años ahora fue una de las primeras
activistas de feil creek dice que la
decisión de aplazamiento de la provincia
no va lo suficientemente lejos queremos
una moratoria un aplazamiento sólo
significa que volveremos a bloquear
cuando termine la clase aliento no
debería funcionar así debería ser una
protección permanente troll entra troll
la lucha por félix se ha convertido en
el mayor movimiento de desobediencia
civil de canadá con más de 1100
detenciones jimmy thompson es el
director del periódico local de capital
daily investigo los métodos violentos
que la policía montada ha utilizado
contra los activistas
cuando los manifestantes me dicen que la
policía montada está siendo
excesivamente violenta y luego me envían
sus historiales hospitalarios
relacionados con su costilla rota si
tiene sentido entienden que pueden
operar básicamente con impunidad porque
hay muy poco acceso a los medios de
comunicación
desde los primeros días de la protesta a
los periodistas también se han
enfrentado a las agresiones de la
policía
es tan frustrante ver eso quiere decir
este tipo es tan ignorante sobre cómo
funciona todo esto y tiene tanto poder
este es el tipo de trato que los medios
de comunicación han sufrido en ferri
creek donde se les impone
arbitrariamente reglas cambiantes y sin
sentido y no tienen otra opción porque
están en medio de la nada varios medios
de comunicación llevaron el caso contra
la policía al tribunal supremo de la
columbia británica que condenó a la
policía por sus intentos de bloquear la
cobertura en faire y crick el movimiento
de protestas una preocupación creciente
para la industria maderera el sector
tiene un valor de 13 mil millones de
dólares es decir el 5% del pib de la
provincia illusions es la principal
empresa maderera que opera en faire y
crick dice estar preocupada por lo que
puede deparar el futuro a sus más de
1000 empleados
nuestra postura es que el bosque antiguo
no está en peligro
los cambios que piden los ecologistas
son de tener al cien por cien la tala de
árboles viejos
es un sinsentido no va a suceder
podemos aplazar la tala unos años más
pero luego llegar a un punto en que se
volverá insostenible
la industria forestal de columbia
británica se ha enfrentado a bloqueos
medioambientales en el pasado a
principios de la década de 1990 miles de
canadienses se movilizaron para salvar
el bosque de clicquot sound y sus
árboles milenarios los manifestantes se
van a ir siempre lo hacen suelen dejar
atrás comunidades indígenas rotas y esto
no será diferente
gary merkel dirigió una revisión
independiente de la gestión de los
bosques antiguos de columbia británica
afirma que son necesarios cambios
significativos para protegerlos
fairy cruyff es lo que yo llamo la punta
del iceberg tenemos que cambiar nuestro
paradigma tenemos que cambiar nuestra
forma de ver el bosque y de pensar en él
tenemos que pasar de un modelo de manejo
de la madera restrictivo a uno que
promueva un ecosistema saludable no se
puede volver a cultivar el bosque
antiguo en muchos lugares y en un plazo
razonable
el gobierno aceptó las 14
recomendaciones del informe de merkel
entre ellas que debe consultar a los
grupos indígenas sobre las decisiones
medioambientales de los bosques en
cuanto a fairey creek se espera que el
tribunal supremo de columbia británica
se pronuncia en los próximos días sobre
si la tala puede continuar